how hard is it to write an emotional
scene
for me personally well I should say for
me personally it's
not as hard and I only say that because
I tend to be very intuitive in my
writing process and a lot of times when
I'm writing I'm feeling it a lot more
than other people are
um
that as an intuitive kind of person I
just have very deep emotions and they
just come out really easily and it's
very easy to spill it on the page
but the challenge for me is actually
getting the audience to feel the same
way
so
on I'm about to say unfortunately
uh it comes down to structure it's
really
if you really want to pull out emotion
it's it has less to do with
depth as it has to do with
the structure of your scene because the
structures walk is gonna
the structure is your frame of your
house but the emotion is the furniture
within it so without that structure of
the house you're just going to have
furniture sitting in the middle of a
field it's just gonna feel weird it's
gonna even if the actor's bringing it
it's still going to be kind of in this
weird nebulous space it's just not
really much of anything but with the
structure
it's what contains everything it's super
vital it get back gets back to the same
kind of stuff we were just talking about
about the importance of goals and stakes
and all kinds of things like that like
if you wanna
I could I could very easily write out an
emotional scene about someone who lost
their father like
you know you could have someone oh I
miss dad and he passed away you know
and if you just tuned in and watched the
one scene and the actress does a great
performance you know pulling that out
yeah it might be compelling
but it's not going to have the impact
that you that you want it to have unless
you understand more about why dad's loss
was so important right where
what that relationship was like that's
all that's all the structure of
backstory and context that you need to
set up so that when we get to emotional
scene it it's paying off in the way that
you mean for it to
otherwise it's just one character
spouting off and just kind of being
emotional
um you know Denzel Washington could pull
that off but
even then if it doesn't have
forward direction to it
um
it's just not going to land the way you
hope and this happens a lot as in my
personal Journey as a screenwriter where
I'm just like so feeling these scenes
that I've written and then other people
read and go yeah this wasn't
quite Landing ah it's so yeah what the
guy's pouring his heart out on paper
yeah it's because there's
the guy's all he's doing is pouring his
hot out on paper without going anywhere
he's just wallowing and there's no point
there's no direction there's there's
do you know it's so much more
you know in the movie Breaking Bad or a
movie the pilot episode of Breaking Bad
there's a fantastic scene in there
where Walter White if you've seen this
show he he starts off as this very
vanilla
spineless guy
and you watch him take this journey
where you learn that he's got cancer
he's gonna die he realizes his life is
over he realizes he's got no savings to
save his family
and then through all this he's realizing
you know he's a chemistry teacher and he
knows about science and all this stuff
um
and he sees that criminals who sell math
make a lot of money and he sees oh
there's a way for me to make a lot of
money right
so he's watching his journey going
through all these steps
and there's this great scene right after
he's bought all the equipment he's
decided he's going to cook meth
and he's this very introverted character
and Jesse comes up to him and says
you know this isn't how I remember you
at all like like at all like you you
were this kind of douche like the just
this lame teacher that just didn't seem
like he cared about anything and all of
a sudden you just have this passion
what is it what happened
and I think the performance of the scene
was very powerful
Walter White looks at him he says I'm
awake it's so simple but it carries so
much of a punch because you had all of
this really good setup framework of his
life and you watch how his life is like
teak things are falling apart he's dying
he's not going to leave anything in this
world and you see him wake up and it
carries the emotional impact because we
saw it we experienced it all with him
and then boom you're hit with it around
that scene I I that's what makes
emotional scenes work now
is it easy to do I don't think it's easy
to do I think it takes a lot of practice
and hard work
but
now if someone else could do all that
work for me and set all that up and then
write in the emotional scene by itself
it's super easy
for me because I think that way but um
yeah the challenge is is all the context
so an emotional scene
where you're just like bleeding in front
of the audience doesn't work unless
there's a setup I mean it could work I
just don't think it's it's not going to
carry the same punch that you want it to
unless they know
why they're feeling this way
why this is such a big moment if I mean
and think of it like if if there is a
character that you're following in a
movie or show and all they do is that
they're constantly emotional it's just a
late it's a chore to watch you don't
want to see it it's too much have you
ever seen a movie that's just so sad and
such a drag that you don't actually want
to watch it again
um that's the kind of feeling you're
gonna get you kind of need the journey
you need the setup you need the context
you need the gold the stakes and all
that to so that once that character does
get to that emotional break
you're in your you want you're on the
journey right with them
so yes it could be powerful on its own
and those are the odd the clips we see
from the Oscars
the best you know first nominee for
Academy Award is Jared Leto and you see
the emotional scene
uh
that's fine for a minute but it's not
going to carry the punch unless you see
the hole thing I don't think did you
watch the Queen's Gambit yeah excellent
did you like it yes very much and this
what I've took from that is that her her
circumstances were showing us this build
up but did she really have any full did
she ever feel sorry for herself it felt
like she didn't and she just turned it
all into the chess matches that's where
she took any type of self-pity or
whatever was beating you know whoever it
was that she wanted to be
that's a good point that's a good point
it's I actually think it's hard to watch
shows where characters feel sorry for
themselves
you know it's
they're out there I can't think of one
an example at the top of my head but I
think it's hard
harder to watch you want to see a
character take their terrible background
and turn it into something make it their
power that's what
that's exciting to watch like the
Queen's Gambit this little girl raise an
orphan suddenly becomes a chess genius
oh I'm in you know like that's awesome
like because she she's the it's a
classic Underdog Story sure if uh you
know if Rocky all did nothing but whine
about his poor background and how he
never got a chance as a boxer and that's
the end it would be hard to watch but
you know he he goes the distance with
Apollo Creed and we're like yeah
so yeah
what was one of the first films to make
you cry oh
you know I have what the first film that
made me cry
I tell you the one that had the biggest
impact on me this is such a weird one
but it was The Prince of Tides I don't
know if you've ever seen that film but
it is a gut wrencher I'm sure that I got
emotional in films
prior to that but that one for some
reason really stands out because it
deals with this guy kind of
coming to terms with his very very
um tragic past
and I will say that
for me
emotions were always very much a
struggle because
they I always looked at them as
something that was weak
which is a problem for a director you
know and someone who tells stories in my
household growing up showing the showing
of vulnerability and emotion was
dangerous it's just not something that
you could do
um
and at and I do remember as I watched
films getting pulled in emotionally
whether it was
sadness tears
or
um Terror those two deep vulnerability
things
were stuff that I tried not to show and
tried very hard to fight it's part of
what made me a filmmaker because when I
would feel terrified or really sad I
would pull myself out and look at the
way the film was constructed
started looking at oh let me oh it's
just an actor sitting there and there's
a director talking to them and oh look
at the interesting lighting you know I
would purposely start to deconstruct the
film to pull myself out of the entire
experience
um
it took me many many years to really
become comfortable with just my own
emotions
I don't know why Prince of Tides
stands if you've ever seen that film
it's a fairy it's Barbra Streisand and
Nick Nolte and he's this kind of big man
and he's
uh he ends up like just sobbing and
breaking down that film really hit me
hard because I think it was very similar
to my own life that's probably why it
stands out to me so much it's one that
just boom
but
emotions
are very key to the the business that
we're in and I think it's really
important to be comfortable with that
especially as a director because
I need to be I'm asking actors to do
that
and I want to be pulled in by that right
I'm asking audiences to be pulled in by
those same emotions well then what am I
doing trying to fight it all the time
and act like I don't feel anything
I maybe I'm in the wrong business if
that's how I'm approaching all of this
learning how to be okay with expressing
emotions I mean
it's taken me a long time but I've
gotten to a point now where I can be on
set talking to an actor and they're just
dumping out you know how they feel and
it's very they're in this very broken
place we're trying to capture that
and I am with them because I want to
show them it's okay so I oftentimes will
be
crying with them so sometimes that will
happen
but I'm also trying to talk to my DP
and the Wardrobe person in between all
of this so I have to be comfortable
enough while I'm in this kind of broken
spot with them to turn to my DP while
I'm
all right so let's grab the 85 and then
when we go on this moment but like not
be for years and years and years I
struggled with that
um position of like ah they're gonna
think I'm ugh what a wuss I had to like
really learn to let that go
um
it helps the entire room when you can
embrace it and just be okay with it it
will I feel like it will be imprinted on
the DNA of the film if you're okay with
it it'll help pull the audience in too
uh
some people are much easier with that
than others I I struggle with it for
many many years um but uh
yeah so Prince of time it's a tough
watch okay I'll have to go back and look
at that
it's an obscure one it's funny that
that's the one that pops into my mind is
the first
but yeah I remember watching that one
it's like
oh it's it's a good movie directed by
Barbra Streisand
and she's in it with Nick Nolte yeah wow
yeah how many movies can you name off
the top of your head that if you saw
them today
they would make you cry
oh
above my head
it's gonna sound so funny jaws and I
tell you why Jaws in the scene when the
little boy is mimicking his dad you know
what I'm talking about where he's he's
having a tough day and uh
and he's just sitting there thinking and
the other boys at the table and he's
like imitating his father and
uh he realizes his son is copying him
and they're going back and forth doing
all these it's just it's just a
beautiful moment and in the end Roy
Scheider leans over to the boy and says
give me a kiss and the kid goes why
because because I need it ah that scene
gets me every time
um you know and I think it's that
definitely like father-son scenes like
the second Guardians of the Galaxy movie
when he wasn't he may have been your
daddy but he may have been your father
but he wasn't your daddy yondu no oh I'm
just a mess anything that deals with
Father and Son coming together and
having this body usually really gets me
um
I uh who off the top of my head
um
oh man I'm gonna think of it like soon
as the camera stops and be like oh this
one and this one and this one and this
one
um
Coda I just watched coded that one got
me
that was if you're familiar with it
stands for children of deaf adults and
it's about a deaf family
and the daughter is can hear the rest of
the family cannot and she wants to do
music It's A Beautiful film
Emily gets me quite a bit it's just this
beautiful love story about her finding
love and it's just so it's just such a
wonderful film um
I'm sure I'll be able to think more
later but yeah yeah and I get more
comfortable with it as I get older of
just like being vulnerable to a lot of
that stuff but yeah